at an event before Al Sharpton's
National Action Network freshman
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
inexplicably transformed into a black
southern preacher we will learn to code
switch then 2020 presidential candidate
Pete but a googa googa googa googa shows
why democrats are obsessed with mike
pence and some radio host calls ben the
antichrist
i've been saying it for years I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
we are going to do a show today we are
going to talk about Alexandria Cassio
Cortes I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I I
forgot who I was talking to I was code
switching we will explain what code
switching is in one second but first
let's make a little money honey with
Lending Club if you are carrying
revolving debt
what are you doing it means you're not
paying off your card every month you
could be paying thousands of dollars in
interest every year that you don't have
to with Lending Club you can consolidate
your debt or pay off credit cards with
one fixed monthly payment since 2007
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club dot-com / Knowles KO wles tell them
about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account as little as a few days it's the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over thirty five billion dollars in
loans issued Lending Club com / Knowles
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 G's that's Lending Club com / Knowles
canna wles
Lending Club com / Knowles canna wles
do not allow high interest credit cards
to ruin your finances act responsibly
take advantage of tools that are
available to you Lending Club com /
Knowles all loans made by web bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender if you
missed it over the weekend you must have
been sleeping underneath Iraq
Alexandria Casio Cortes last Friday
speaking before Al Sharpton's groups
called the National Action Network she
tried out a new accent that we have
never heard from her before see if you
can pick up on this really subtle change
to her diction is what organizing looks
like this is what building power looks
like this is what changing the country
looks like it's when we choose to show
up and occupy the room
and talk about the things that matter
most talking about our future you know
Reverend you bring up a funny anecdote
and I'm proud to be a bartender ain't
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with working retail folding
clothes for other people to buy there is
nothing wrong with preparing the food
that your neighbors will eat there is
nothing wrong with driving the buses
that take your family to work there's
nothing wrong about elongating all of
the vowels in your statements ain't
nothing wrong with that
do you notice she was you if you quit
you might have been able to hear it but
she's clapping as she's saying it said
this is what organizing looks like it's
like that tweet that that emoji on the
tweet this meme that goes around where
you punctuate every word with a clap
this is supposed to be a very I don't
know I guess I guess it's supposed to be
ethnic pandering that's what she's doing
she's speaking in front of a primarily
black audience and she's affecting what
she imagines to be the accent of a black
person this obviously immediately drew
comparisons to Hillary Clinton one of
the I can't even watch it I don't like
Hillary Clinton I know that she is a
terrible politician I know that she's a
total Pandora completely disingenuous
even for me this is so difficult to
watch in 2007 Hillary Clinton is
speaking before a predominantly black
audience and she decides to change her
accent I don't feel no ways tired
[Applause]
from where I started from nobody told me
that the road would be easy
I don't believe he brought me this far
to leave me it was so difficult for me
to watch to the end of that clip but I
did think you know I've come too far
from where I've started from nobody told
me that watching Hilary would be easy
absolutely not
what is a OCS excuse what is Hilary's
excuse hey OC had a better excuse than
Hilary did then she said that what she
was doing is an example of
code-switching
this is a brilliant excuse it doesn't
hold up it's totally flat but it's
basically the only thing she could have
said code-switching
is when you speak one way to one group
of people and then you speak a different
way in your personal life so it's the
idea that because you come from a
cultural minority or a racial minority
or a linguistic minority that when you
speak in public you have to speak in a
more formal way in a more linguistically
correct way but then when you're
speaking among your own people among
your own culture then you revert to your
more authentic more casual language now
all of us to a certain degree have to
speak more formally in public it's
better it's more civilized for us to
speak more formally in public I've
talked about how when I go to a bar I'll
talk like a sailor but when I speak in
public regardless of the venue I really
try not to because I think it degrades
discourse and it's it's disrespectful
and it's undignified now is that
code-switching I don't know when I go
down everybody to a certain degree does
this kind of code-switching
here's an example I'm half of my family
as waspy in English the other half is
Italian I grew up in New York I went to
school in New England when I would be at
school in New England I would speak a
certain way among people who also speak
that way when I would go down to the
Bronx on Arthur Avenue to buy super SOT
when I was growing up at the Italian
marketplace I would speak a different
way just a little you're pronouncing
certain words a little differently
certain Italian words a little
differently that I guess you could call
that code-switching that's what AOC is
trying to say that she did everybody
does this to a certain degree
however what she did is not
code-switching
because it's not the case that she has
learned how to speak in a more formal
way publicly but her actual personal
authentic speech is as a black southern
preacher alexandria cassia Cortez is not
naturally and authentically and
genuinely a black southern preacher that
is not she's she's not code-switching
she's pretending to be someone else
politicians and actors do this naturally
they do it all the time she might not
even have been aware that she was doing
it this is the the only skill that you
need as a politician or as an actor is
you have to have a keen and even
unconscious sense of empathy such that
when you're talking to the butcher in
the Bronx at the Italian market maybe
you pronounce things a little bit
differently just naturally because
they're pronouncing things a little bit
differently and you're relating to them
and then when you're in a in a poetry
seminar in New England you're speaking a
little differently as well okay that's a
that's the natural thing this is when
actors are onstage actors are reacting
to imaginary circumstance it's the
difference for the politician is the
politician is supposed to live in
reality you the politician isn't
supposed to just be putting on a show
and in Alexandria cassia Cortez's case
the notion that the way that she was
speaking was really just her code
switching and reverting to her authentic
speech is demonstrably false for a few
reasons she wrote on Twitter she said
quote as much as the right wants to
distort and deflect I am from the Bronx
I act and talk like it especially when
I'm fired up and especially when I'm
home
it is so hurtful to see how every aspect
of my life is weaponized against me
yet somehow asserted is false at the
same time the reason that this is false
is because one she did not grow up in
the Bronx she did not do that also even
if she did grow up in the Bronx that is
not how people talk in the Bronx how do
I know this how do I know all of this I
do have a unique vantage here
in that Alexandria Casio Cortez and I
have in certain ways parallel lives were
basically the same age born within a
year of each other when we were both
very little our families lived in the
borough's she lived in the Bronx I lived
in Sheepshead Bay Brooklyn all the way
out before elementary school both of our
families moved up not just to the
suburbs not just to Westchester not just
to Northern Westchester but to towns
right next to each other right across
the new Croton reservoir from one
another she grew up in Yorktown Heights
which is relatively more affluent and
relatively less ethnically diverse and I
grew up in Bedford Hills the median
household income in Yorktown Heights is
about nine nine thousand dollars a year
ninety nine or $100,000 the median
household income in Bedford Hills about
sixty eight thousand dollars both very
affluent places however she grew up in
the more affluent place and when she's
talking about code-switching
worth pointing out that Yorktown Heights
where she grew up is between 80 to 90
percent 82 and 90 percent white do you
know how black it is do you know what
the black percentage of the population
is between 0.99 and 2% black so
something tells me she didn't just learn
this she didn't just hear this growing
up this was Don lemons defense of her he
said look she's from the Bronx she talks
she knows a lot of black people this is
how she talks to black people she's done
it a lot no she didn't grow up in the
Bronx she grew up in a place where
basically there aren't any black people
and that is not her authentic voice now
maybe you might say okay
AOC would visit her friends relatives in
the Bronx on the weekends maybe she
picked it up there again here personal
experience tells me this isn't true I
was down in the Bronx every single
weekend grocery shopping seeing friends
I never magically transformed into a
black preacher I went down countless
times to the Bronx somehow it never
transformed me into a cartoon and a
caricature of a black preacher
she says she's code switching which code
is she switching to she's not code
switching she is not reverting back to
her authentic accent she is performing a
caricature of what she thinks
southern black drawl sounds like and it
sounds nearly as fake is when Hillary
Clinton did it and then what does she do
she immediately refers to her allegedly
hardscrabble upbringing and her false
claim that she grew up in the Bronx
this is a lie on her campaign website in
2018 she said that her life was defined
by the 40-minute commute between her
family in the Bronx and school in the
suburbs not true in the state of New
York you you don't just get to commute
from a bad neighborhood in the Bronx to
whatever public school you want to go to
upstate that's not how it works you get
district it into your school if that
were the case everybody in a bad school
district in the city would just commute
up to the suburbs she did not commute
she lived there she lived there from the
age of five all the way until 2016
according to Westchester land records
according to Westchester County land
records until a year or two before she
ran for Congress from Queens she lived
with her parents not just in Westchester
but in a very ritzy part of Northern
Westchester that is not her upbringing
it's not being weaponized against her
the only thing that is being used as a
weapon against her is her obvious lie
about where she comes from and some
people have said to me Michael Michael
stop it don't talk about her obvious
fraud just talk about the craziness of
her proposals no this is a bad idea you
have to point out that she is a fraud
through and through look there's this
conspiracy theory it's sort of half a
conspiracy theory that a OC was cast in
the role of being a congress
congressional candidate that actually
she's just an actress this is half true
and so much as she did audition for a
political action committee which were
her and remain still to this day her
backers in her political career doesn't
mean she's just an actress she might
have had an interest in politics and the
difference between politics and show
business gets blurry sometimes but it's
so important to focus on this fraud
because this is what she always goes
back to she says you're just attacking
me because I grew up in a in an
underprivileged environment you're just
going after me
because I'm from the Bronx you're just
going after me because listen I I don't
know how to use the English language
properly because I grew up in this bad
neighborhood in the Bronx and we had bad
schooling know the way to expose all of
those lines to cut off all of her
defences at the knees is to point out
that she is a total fraud through and
through she for her entire conscious
life grew up in an extremely wealthy
privileged area of Westchester County
she attended a very good school district
Yorktown high school she then went to a
very expensive private college in
Massachusetts Boston University which
costs seventy two thousand dollars per
year to attend and then she moved right
back to her mother's house after college
and lived there until basically she
decided to run for Congress
she had as privileged and upbringing as
you can possibly have on earth in the
grand scheme of all of human history
virtually nobody is at a more privileged
upbringing than Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
she was taught the English language
perfectly well she does not have a
Southern drawl a cartoon drawl that she
thinks is going to pander to her
audience it's just a lie which code was
she switching to she really what you
know there was that that hashtag that
was going around on Twitter for a while
learned to code this is what people said
to the journalists who lost their jobs
who for years told coal miners to learn
to code we need to tell aoc to learn to
code switch this is not credible and by
the way look we're still talking about
her she's still getting herself in the
headlines she's beginning to I think
she's not no longer the left Trump I
think the left liked her because she was
sort of their version of Trump very
media savvy outrageous was able to
really rile up her opponents but she
keeps losing and Donald Trump hasn't
lost yet if he loses in 2020 that'll
change the calculus but he has he keeps
winning that's sort of the defining
feature of Donald Trump AOC
keeps humiliating herself and we should
shine a spotlight on that
not just on her crazy policies but on
this silly grievance premise because it
isn't true and if you don't listen not
everyone knows what Westchester's like
not everyone knows the inner politics
they're not everyone knows what Yorktown
high school is like okay I am from there
I grew up eight miles away from where
she grew up I am Telling You for sure
it's so funny because people come up to
me and they say Michael you you're such
a rich kid you're such a spoiled rich
kid you you're such a patrician you're
and I don't answer these attacks
I find it undignified I find it
distasteful I I will not get into a
tit-for-tat saying my mother cleaned
more floors for less money than your
mother as Mike Bloomberg famously
described I will not do that I find it's
so ugly and awful I find it so ugly to
boast about experiences of poverty as
though this were some something to be
proud of some metal to wear on your
chest the only time I will inject
personal experience is simply to point
out I lived almost the exact upbringing
that AOC did and she is pretending
constantly to be Jenny from the block
now she's pretending to be mrs. Al
Sharpton and it just is not the case I
come from that neighborhood I come from
the same block that AOC came from it
this does not mold you naturally into
some caricature in a cartoon of what the
left thinks grievance politics should
look like
speaking of grievance politics we've got
Pete Buddy gagaga he is the mayor of
South Bend Indiana who's now running for
president because mayors of South Bend
Indiana I guess run for president and he
is openly gay he's gay married he's
making this a big part of his campaign
and he was speaking at some left-wing
fundraiser and Pete Buddy googa
highlighted one of the bizarre Democrat
obsessions over the last three or four
years which is that Democrats are
obsessed with Mike Pence you think that
Republicans are obsessed with Alexandria
cassio Cortez doesn't hold a candle to
the way that Democrats are obsessed with
Mike Pence
specifically Mike Pence's sex life
you'll remember there was a big story
this was big news Mike Pence won't have
dinner alone with women unless his wife
is present this was big news he was
raked over the coals for this I got into
long back some back and forth with my
Democrat friends who said it's so awful
that he won't have dinner alone with
women how I'm sexist a misogynist by the
way about three months later the me2
movement happened and then all these men
who were having private dinners with
women too turned out they were all
sexual predators turned out they were
virtually all Democrats but no know that
they've kind of forgot them then they go
back to Mike Pence and they think that
he hates gay people there is no evidence
for this whatsoever
none at all the one bit of evidence is
that he once voted for a giant bill or
advocated voting for a giant bill among
all bazillion bills he ever voted for in
Congress and this bill would have
permitted some of the healthcare funding
to go toward certain therapy techniques
for gay men who go to therapists and
want to try to change their sexual
preferences and this was transformed
into Mike Pence want to wants to
electrocute gays and hates gays there's
a big they Olympians gay Olympians I I'm
gonna shake Mike Pence's hand yeah
that'll show him oh yeah they're gonna
dig up yeah this this lesbian is gonna
go shake Mike Pence's hand that'll show
him Mike Pence doesn't care I promise
you Mike Pence does not care Mike Pence
is a politician he shakes everybody's
hand he's been a politician for a very
long time he's he has met gay people I
think it's just fine but people gotta
but I gotta go get a but I gotta is
pushing this line in his 2020
presidential campaign speaking only for
myself I can tell you that if me being
gay was a choice it was a choice that
was made far far above my paygrade
[Applause]
and that's the thing I wish the Mike
Pence's of the world would understand if
you got a problem with Who I am
your problem is not with me your quarrel
sir is with my Creator okay lot to
dissect here he refuses the phrase the
Mike Pence's of the world presumably as
a stand-in for anti-gay bigot and so
here is the premise the premise is the
same premise that Anthony Kennedy had in
oberfeld in the gay marriage case the
premise is that if you object to
redefining marriage from what it has
always meant for all of human history in
every single culture everywhere in the
world until about five minutes ago
to now also include monogamous but not
polygamous same-sex unions if you object
to that in any way you are a hateful
bigot who has a quote irrational animus
for gay people the Mike Pence's of the
world more broadly it's the idea that if
you take the traditional view of sexual
morality which holds that sex outside of
marriage including gay sex acts is to be
held in moral opprobrium this is the
traditional view of Christianity of
Judaism of Islam of all the theistic
religions and of just about every
society in the history of the world if
you take that view of sexual morality
you are a hateful vicious bigot this is
this is the view that Pete but a Gungan
big [ __ ] is espousing this is a very
modern view this is a regardless of your
opinion by the way on gay acts or gay
sex or gay inclinations or gay
preferences or gay marriage regardless
of your view on that you must at least
concede that Pete buddy gov is view is
extraordinarily modern Hillary Clinton
ran in 2008 and said that marriage is
the sacred bond between a man and a
woman Barack Obama said the same thing
until 2012 until seven years ago this
was the prevailing view even among
far left of the Democrat Party and now
we are told that if you don't hold the
view that homosexual acts are not just
not to be held in moral of program not
just morally neutral but actually
morally good if you don't hold that view
you are a hateful bigot this is a very
modern very minority point of view but
that is what people but a Gaga Gaga is
saying and he's saying it to smear not
only Mike Pence but anybody who holds to
the traditional teachings of any of the
theistic religions and it's it's a
cynical attack because they go after
Mike Pence
I wonder what does a practicing Muslim
think of gay sex or gay marriage what is
a practicing Muslim what is Ilan Omar I
know Ilan Omar has won the support of
certain gay rights groups because she's
says that she'll be a left-wing vote in
the house alone Omar is a practicing
Muslim Islam holds homosexual acts in
moral opprobrium how come no one's going
after Allah no more how come no one
wants the ilan Omar to clarify her state
her stance on homosexuality
you know Mike Pence has never voted to
discriminate against gay people Mike
Pence has never voted to outlaw gay sex
Mike Pence has never done any of that
Mike Pence and kneel on Omar are
basically exactly the same in their
actual record on the so-called gay
issues issues specifically pertaining to
homosexuality how come buddy gagaga
isn't going to say Alon Omar will you
condemn your religions traditional view
on homosexuality you know what I want to
ask the ill on Omar's of the world if
they believe that my Creator made a
mistake and this is the second part of
his argument which is a bad faith
argument which is funny because there
are many meanings to that phrase and all
of them are correct this is a bad faith
argument to say that there is no
discussion to be had on sexual morality
because peace unborn this way right that
isn't the point the the the traditional
theistic argument against homosexuality
is that yeah people are born all sort
of ways and but it's an imperfect and
fallen world and therefore we can hold
certain behaviors and natural
inclinations in moral opprobrium
that's the traditional view you might
disagree with that view you might
disagree with the view that
homosexuality is a part of the fallen
nature of man you might say it's a
prelapsarian aspect of human nature
okay have that argument but it but if
you're saying that by virtue of the fact
that I was born with certain
inclinations and certain desires that
those desires are there for good
therefore instituted and blessed by God
that is not a legitimate argument it's a
bad faith argument that's an argument
designed to obfuscate the the question
and it's a question by the way that only
Pete by de gagaga is bringing up you'll
notice nobody in the GOP no
conservatives are saying that Pete buddy
gugga is unqualified and not a
legitimate presidential candidate
because he's a gay guy find me one
person who said that one mainstream or
prominent Republican or conservative who
said that nobody is bringing up that
issue the only one who is bringing it up
is Pete Buddy gagaga and he's not doing
it to defend against the Mike Pence's of
the world he's doing it to attack the
Mike Pence's of the world and to say
that unless you agree with me 100% on an
extraordinarily new radical extreme view
of sexual morality you're a hateful
awful bigot and you're not fit for
polite society outrageous bullying
outrageous radicalism and all on the
offense none on the defense that's going
to be Pete but again why is people to
googa googa doing it it's because that's
his only chance to win the Democrat
primary Pete buddy Gaga is a white guy
an Ivy league-educated white guy who was
in the military that is not going to
play very well in the intersectional
Olympics of the Democrat 2020 primary
there was a piece the other day I think
was in the New York Times that said is
Pete does Pete Buddy gagas homosexuality
count as diversity or is he just another
white male so he's gonna have to play up
the fact that he's gay a fact that I
don't think anybody really cares about
and he's going to tilt
windmills and pretend that there is some
massive oppression in the country that
we have to fight against because he's so
terribly underprivileged and oppressed
what a tedious argument what a
disingenuous arguing what a totally bad
faith argument we have got to get to
Kirsten Nielsen the DHS secretary is out
over the border crisis we will also get
to lies from CBS we'll also get to
Chelsea Handler's midlife crisis and if
we have time we'll get to Ben Shapiro as
the Antichrist but first go to Daly
wire.com ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
under Clavin show you got the ben
shapiro show you get them out wall show
you test questions in the mailbag coming
up on thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get all sorts of things
and you get the leftist here's tumblr
this is very important mm-hmm oh yeah
some people say that drinking all these
leftist tears is exhausting but I don't
feel no ways tired I come too far from
where I started from
nobody told me guzzling these tears
would be easy go to daily wire comm get
your tumblr we'll be right back with a
lot more
got the whole second half of the show I
don't feel no way it's tired I'm gonna
have that in my head all day like it's a
bad song Kirsten Nielsen the Secretary
of the Department of Homeland Security
is out she's been on shaky ground for a
long time president Trump has been
criticizing her for a long time people
thought she would be fired or resigned
in December or earlier she's lasted this
long she was apparently an ally of John
Kelly I believe the the ousted chief of
staff once he was gone there was some
question as to whether she would remain
and now she's finally out what is she
out over it's all about the border
crisis apparently President Trump is not
pleased with her handling of the issue
of illegal immigration which is a
central issue for his administration so
she's out we got a new guy in we'll see
if he'll do any better I'm not really
interested in her tenure which was fine
whatever we've been talking about
illegal immigration for a long time
you've seen how she's handled it you've
seen how she's been stymied by the
courts you've seen how she has been
stymied by certain laws so the question
is what is the reaction to her tenure
what is the reaction to her leaving
richard blumenthal the senator from
connecticut who lied about serving in
vietnam and president Trump now refers
to him as Danang Richard Danang Richard
goes on MSNBC on KC hunts show and he
lambaste s' Kirsten Nielsen in a totally
unfair attack grace as Secretary of
Homeland Security and she leaves behind
a legacy of separating families caging
children and lying about those policies
but in addition to that legacy she still
leaves behind a strategy make no mistake
that strategy has been one of conscious
and purposeful cruelty seeking to deter
and discourage people from coming to
this country making that trip of
hundreds of miles across the impossible
terrain with
children in their arms knowing that they
faced cruel conditions here on their
arrival there are many many lies in that
statement but there's one truth which is
at the end they said people are coming
hundreds and hundreds of miles with
children in their arms trying to get
into this country right there are many
coyotes who are coming into this country
trafficking children there are many
people bringing children who are not
their own children because of illegal
immigration we can't vet them we don't
they don't have papers we don't know who
they who the children are we don't know
who their parents are we don't know
where their parents are we don't know
who is coming into this country it's a
very dangerous situation
that leaves according to fusion and
Amnesty International between 60 and 80
percent of women and girls who come into
the country illegally it leaves them
raped and sexually assaulted and 70
percent of the people who cross into
this country illegally or suffer
violence on the perilous journey those
that is happening because of the open
borders policies that Danang Richard is
advocating the he's he's lambasted
people for trying to get those numbers
under control trying to discourage what
is causing all of that widespread misery
that's that's on the people who are
promoting that policy now he says that
kjerstan Nielsen's legacy is one of
disgrace and caging children this is
what the New York Times said the same
thing they said that her legacy is
enforcing cruelty at the border she
caged children you remember the photos
of those poor children being caged
during kjerstan Nielsen's tenure in the
Trump administration right wrong those
photos that went viral everyone blamed
Kirsten Nielson and Donald Trump for
were from 2014 who was president in 2014
I know it feels like Trump has been
president forever there was a man in
2014 who was president named Barack
Obama Barack Obama caged children now no
one cares nobody actually cares because
this if this awful situation what does
it really mean by cages and means
putting them in prisons putting them in
certain holding areas and no one
actually cares because where you gonna
put them in a sir
won't you run out of places to put
illegal aliens you run enough places to
put even kids who need to be taken care
of who don't have people to look after
them when they enter the country
illegally you put them somewhere I
actually don't even really blame Barack
Obama's administration for this but it
was Obama who caged the children and
cynical Richard Blumenthal didn't say so
much as a peep when that was happening
because he doesn't really care he's
using something that Barack Obama did as
a cudgel to attack
Kirsten Nielsen but it isn't the case
how about separating the children from
the Paris at the border that's a--that's
a Donald Trump's fault right that's
Kirsten Nielsen's fault right
no it's actually not even Barack Obama's
fault it's the fault of the courts under
Bill Clinton the Flores agreement the
much-discussed Flores agreement which is
responsible for separating kids from
their families of the borders was
decided in 1997 during the Clinton
administration and why was it decided it
was decided because you can't imprison
children so the parents come into the
country illegally they've committed a
major crime you have to hold them so
they are processed by the criminal
justice system but what about the kids
you can't hold the kids in prison
indefinitely that's a horrible idea so
what the Flores agreement decided was
that you could only put kids in prisons
with their parents for a short period of
time then they have to be handled
not by prisons but by the Department of
Health and Human Services they have to
go to nicer places than jails and
prisons okay fair enough therefore they
have to be separated from their parents
the only way not to separate them from
their parents is to let everybody go
which is to say the only way to not
separate them from their parents the
only way to not engage in cruel behavior
as Democrats selectively refer to this
is to say the borders are open anybody
can come in without any vetting that's
the only way or you close the border
entirely or you have open borders which
is why at the very bottom of this
immigration debate and all of the
demagoguery over the kids being caged
and Families separated and cruel
at the very bottom you have a debate
over having borders and enforcing the
laws that have been on the books for
decades and decades or not enforcing the
laws at all and having effectively open
borders those are the two positions
that's it and what Richard Blumenthal is
saying and what the New York Times
editorial board is saying what they're
all saying is we would rather that the
Secretary of Homeland Security not
enforce the law we would rather that
President Trump not enforce the law we
think it is just and fair and wonderful
and good and equitable if we do not
enforce our laws we do not allow the
people of the United States to govern
themselves through their representatives
through their representative
institutions we want to overturn the
right of the people to govern themselves
because we think that random
bureaucratic czars enforcing our
preferred policy according to their own
whims is is more just it is an assault
on our republic it is an assault on a
representative democracy it's an assault
on the law are we a nation of laws or a
nation of the whims of individuals are
we a nation with borders the definition
of a nation or are we not a nation it's
a radical attack that the Democrats and
the left are engaging in it's not just
about have compassion for the kids at
the border it's not just about that that
is the the sentimental demagoguery
plucking on your heartstrings to push
through a radical radical proposition
which is that we must cease to be a
country of laws we must cease to be a
country of self-government
we must ultimately cease to be a country
at all and surrender our national
sovereignty to super national
transnational international organization
and arrangements that are utterly
unaccountable to the American people
that's what they want that's what
they're pushing for more dishonest
politics in history from the left-wing
comes in the way of CBS CBS was running
a piece on the civil war reconstruction
before and after the Civil War see if
you can notice something about how they
organized their Civil War maps and how
about this for a second act after
returning home to Beaufort South
Carolina Robert smalls
was elected to the US House of
Representatives one of more than a dozen
African Americans to serve in Congress
during the period known as
reconstruction when the formerly rebel
states were reabsorbed into the Union
and four million newly freed African
Americans were made citizens this is why
you've got to subscribe because you
could hear I bet you know exactly what
they did so first of all they don't
mention that that gentleman went as as
did all of the black people representing
now now representing their or
constituencies in the Congress they were
all Republicans they don't mention that
but then they show the map of the United
States in the former rebel states being
reabsorbed into the country guess what
colors they use they represent the north
in blue and they represent the south in
red and then those red rebels
conservative Republicans were absorbed
into the Union oh except wait a minute
that's not what happened at all that's
not what happened at all the Civil War
was a war between Republicans and
Democrats the Republicans fighting to
free the slaves and maintain the Union
Democrats fighting to maintain the
institution of slavery and secede from
the union but they have to flip it and
it will they say one of their lines is
they say well the two parties switched
at some point so when did they switch
when did the Republicans and the
Democrats all just sit down at a table
in this okay I know for a hundred years
you've been Democrats and we've been
Republicans but now we're gonna switch
for some reason so you're gonna be the
Republicans we're gonna be the Democrats
okay and why are we gonna do this
absolutely no reason at all and
what date is this gonna happen on we're
not gonna know because nobody's ever
gonna be able to point to it okay
did not happen now do political
questions change over time do political
movements change over time yes of course
is the Republican Party of today exactly
the same as the Republican Party of 1865
no is the Democrat Party exactly the
same no are there certain similarities
yes there are and what the CBS News is
trying to do is what the left has long
tried to do which is rewrite the history
of the United States such that the
horrific history of the Democrat Party
and it is a brutal and horrific and
disgraceful history becomes attributed
to Republicans and the rather good
history of the Republican Party is
attributed to Democrats that's what
they're always trying to do so any time
I mean even down to the fact that they
won't mention that all of those
representatives were Republicans they
just won't mention it they can't mention
it cuts too much against their narrative
it's so dishonest and it does remind me
we cannot trust the mainstream media for
anything I know this seems like an
obvious point conservatives have known
this for a long time the problem is so
much worse than even I thought it was
these lies these casual lies are the
entirety of mainstream media reporting
on all the news networks and on CNN and
MSNBC in The New York Times in the
Washington Post they have no credibility
at all just consider I mean this is one
good example but the biggest news story
of the last two years the Russia hoax
collusion investigation they all got it
completely and consistently wrong for
two years all of them have got the
biggest story before that the Donald
Trump could win the presidential
election they all got it completely and
consistently wrong the entire time how
about the biggest story before that
which was ostensibly Russian
interference in the election and more
importantly Barack Obama's
administration's interference in the
election FISA abuse surveillance
collusion they all got that completely
and consistently wrong from the very
beginning they continued to get it wrong
the the biggest stories what are they
good for all they do is pump out lies
and they get into tens of millions of
homes every night to pump out more lies
just like this it's a big problem
speaking of crazy leftists there was
actually a beautiful clip that came from
Chelsea Handler on Bill Maher show I
know this is shocking I know one could
not imagine she's the alleged comedian
who admits to doing depraved and bizarre
acts in her own personal life and is
certainly a little mentally unbalanced
she admitted that this unbalanced played
a role in her reaction to president
Trump's election on Bill Maher I think
this is painfully honest and I think
that a lot more leftists should talk as
bluntly as she is you know I'm reading
your book and I'm feeling like a bad
friend because I didn't realize you were
suffering so my movie Oh everybody took
the 2016 election hard but I didn't know
it really knocked you down like that and
it came you came back stronger that's
what the book is about yeah I had a
midlife identity crisis once Trump won
the election because I had never had my
world filled so feel so unhinged I think
and I had to pay a psychiatrist to
listen to me about Donald Trump for
about the first three weeks and then
once we got past that and we got to the
real stuff I realized the parallel there
was my world becoming unhinged when I
was a little girl my brother died when I
was nine years old I had never related
the two but for me as I can imagine it
must have been for so many people it was
a huge emotional trigger of everything
being destabilized and I realized just
how spoiled and privileged I'd been all
my life to realize they should be this
upset in this out of ten every day and
the outrage and the anger I just wanted
to fight people you know and I was like
I gotta go see it for psychiatrists yes
you did it's good that you saw a
psychiatrist it's good that you're
realizing this maybe the whole left
should go see a psychiatrist maybe a
psychologist I don't think they need me
more drugs but certainly a psychologist
what Chelsea Handler is admitting is
that the left's reaction to President
Trump
Trump derangement syndrome is a
psychological reaction it's not a
political reaction it's not a
philosophical reaction it's not an
historical or economic reaction it is a
psychological twitch that has a very
little bearing in reality she is saying
that President Trump got elected this
Center spiraling down into this crazy
depression crisis because it reminded
her of childhood traumas basically
saying it was all daddy issues which
I've been saying for two years since
Donald Trump got elected they're not
reacting to the reality of the Trump
administration they're reacting to their
own weird daddy issues and a lot of
people have a lot of daddy issues these
days I mean I get it I get it we our
country has exploding rates of anxiety
exploding rates of depression exploding
rates of stress we can get into maybe
we'll get into this a little bit
tomorrow I have an op dad examining why
that might be but we have total family
breakdown we have people being raised
without religious moorings we have a lot
of social ills in the country and so
people are reacting to relatively
trivial or ordinary political events as
though they are the end of the world
it's a weird psychological twitch in
many cases she's admitting it I applaud
her for her honesty I wish more
left-wingers would be more honest but I
guess that's probably asking a little
bit too much okay that's the show it's
been a long show I feel some ways tired
I've come too far to keep doing this
show so come back tomorrow we've got a
lot more to talk about a lot more we
should have gotten to but you know
that's how it goes
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael nolde show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today some students and faculty at
Baylor are now saying that my presence
on their campus for my speech on Tuesday
night poses a threat to their physical
well-being what does that even mean
we'll we'll try to figure that out also
AOC humiliates herself by adopting a
fake accent and Gillett is now
celebrating morbid obesity is that
enlightened and progressive or is it
dangerous we'll discuss today over on
the Matt Walsh show